voici maintenant l'histoire de saint
germain des prés à travers des photos et
un comédien c'est notre rubrique un
livre un auteur un quartier le saint
germain des années 50 décrit par le
comédien daniel gélin qui avait vingt
ans après guerre et photographié par de
façon superbe par georges dudognon des
souvenirs comme on sait mais à saint
germain des prés c'est le titre de ce
livre
reportage de jean jacques mazier club
saint germain 23 mètres au dessous du
niveau de la mer la cave par excellence
et sous l'oeil des dieux
les penseurs cage honneur rue saint
benoît
le club saint germain l'une des
nombreuses caves photographiée par
georges du dognon entre 1945 et 55 dans
ces lieux enfumés défaite mémorable pour
oubliées les années noires ici duke
ellington charlie parker django
reinhardt ou boris vian auprès lancer
une genèse qui découvrait la liberté
d'après guerre
georges dudognon était là à chaque fois
qu'il se passait quelque chose
son rolleiflex à la main pour des
instantanés devenu documents d'époque
défaut de ruches est un hommage
ses quartiers dans cette époque il n'y
avait pas de distinguo entre le connus
ou les méconnus on pouvait très bien
s'adresser à sartre en lui disant ben
voila je suis dans le besoin ce que vous
pourriez pas et chartres est toujours
une liasse de billets habite à saint
germain des prés et fac aux sports
gérante et la vie en plein jour se
passer aux terrasses des cafés dans les
restaurants et brasseries autour de
l'église saint germain une vie de
village où chaque germanopratin voulait
croire que tout était possible
saint germain des prés univers de
création capital de l'existentialisme
animé par prévert sartre vian mouloudi
ou gréco très poussée avec avec sa
pouvoir les frères lapentti
même avec prévert vous avec amon tanoh
et dit bien que vous sortez enrichi de
ses conversations qui avait lui si on
parlait fort lisez par l'équipe ici il y
avait en lisez le dernier gallimard
lisais dernièrement américain s'activait
c'était une espèce de petite université
avec des consommations soit pour venais
souvent ici je dois dire que non
et curieusement mais mes enfants ma
nouvelle siona xavier même
même la petite laura maintenant via
l'app elle trouve qu'il existe encore
quelques je voyais des pentes au mieux
les fantômes des preuves unique à chaque
métier était la révélation par georges
dudognon et daniel gélin n'ont pas
cherché à écrire l'histoire de cette
époque sans aucune nostalgie ils se
souviennent simplement de leur jeunesse
il avait 20 ans et un besoin vital ordre
oubliées les années d'occupation